All these connections went together beautifully and this system is looking amazing. What's up guys welcome back to the shop today
We are jumping into some hardcore diy for today's video
We're gonna be building a flamethrower now in one of my more recent videos
I jumped out of the comments and found a suggestion from this anonymous user who asks Grant
I know this is crazy, but so are you could you make a flamethrower?
I think that sounds like a fantastic idea, so that's what we're doing for this video today this comment got
3385 Thumbs Ups that's Absolutely Ridiculous
So apparently a lot of you want to see this so let's jump right in so in preparing for this project today
I thought rather than
Reinvent the wheel why not find somebody who's already built a flamethrower and work with their design so after a bit of searching on Google?
I found this thing how to make a flamethrower to do-it-yourself manual perfect right so a little bit context of this situation
I went ahead and purchased these plans only cost about $30
And I'll leave a link in the description if you want to get them for yourself
There's about a hundred pages of detailed information
Which can be very overwhelming so the purpose of this video today is to show you my experience following these step-by-step
Instructions from Flamethrower plans calm by the way, this is not a sponsored video. I paid for everything you see here
I just wanted to give credit where Credit's due. I'm gonna break this tutorial into two different parts the first one is a familiarization
I'm gonna show you all the equipment all the parts that you're gonna need and the basic assembly
in the second part of this video
We're gonna do some of the more complicated tasks like modifying the tank and torch
One of the cool things this guy did in this pdf is he put Amazon affiliate links to all the materials you need so I
literally
Just open up the PDf click all the links and just order immediately the total cost of all the materials ended up being right around
450 Dollars plus the $30 for the plan so all-in-all this is about a five hundred Dollar Bill
So Amazon delivered all the parts. I got everything together, so let's take a look at what we got so starting over here
We got a 24 ounce Co2 tank like they use for paintball. We got a paintball universal fill adapter
We got a four and a half inch length of eighth inch metal tubing this is male
NPT and 0.3 20 cGa female two eighth inch female
NpT and that whole assembly there is going to attach this tank here in just a few minutes next we've got the assemblies for the
Pressure washer hose and handle so start off with a pressure washer gun and you can see there's no
Nozzle or attachment for the end here
And that's okay because we're gonna add an m 22 male by quarter inch female
NPt a quarter inch male NPT by eighth inch PML empty reducer a three-inch length of male tubing NPT to nPT and
1/8 inch female to female
NPC coupler the hoses three feet long it's 4,000 PSI rated and it came with the connectors which screws into the
Pressure washer handle itself and the threaded end connects to the M22 male by quarter inch female adapter
This is a 3/8 inch male quick disconnect
This is a 3/8 inch female
Disconnect to Male NPT then a female
Mpt 2 female quick disconnect and a male quick disconnect to female nPT coupler other than that the only accessories
We really need are one and a half millimeter shrink wrap 2 large quick disconnect. Hose clamps and a propane torch
This is a 20-pound Co2 tank it can hold a lot of pressure and to mount it up on our backs
We're using a Scuba back harness. I should also mention. I picked up some of this plumber's tape for threading and connections
I usually use white for pipe threads, but in this case. We want to go yellow because yellow specifically designed for plumbing applications
We've got all our parts laid out in order of assembly you already know what they are now
So let's go ahead and put them all together
We got the 24-ounce tank feeding into the 20 pound tank and next we assemble the hose
We're also Gonna have to get this harness
Check it out guys flamethrower is just about done all these connections went together beautifully, and this system is looking amazing
I cannot wait to test it out after going through this process myself
It seems like the hardest thing really is just getting the right materials
But if you use this guy's PdF download from the links he's already got on there everything seems to fit together pretty well there are
Just a couple more modifications
We need to make this is where things start getting a little bit more complicated
So I'm going to show you how to do this in the next video
But essentially we're gonna take this hose plug it into the tank and add a propane torch underneath the handle here
So we have a source of ignition
And of course a big shout-out to this anonymous user for suggesting we actually build a flamethrower and forgetting over
3000 thumbs Ups good job man and go check your YouTube inbox for saying 25 bucks. Thanks for joining me for this project today
I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
like the Stanley cup
Hey real quick you remember this guy, this is nate
just wanted to pop in real quick and let you know that I'm
Prototyping some new projects for the show and looking forward to joining
You here on the king of random in the very near future see you then